y
[Música]
los expertos chinos y de la organización
mundial de la salud investigaron en un
plan el origen del cob y 19 consideran
que es extremadamente improbable que el
nuevo coronavirus se haya filtrado de un
laboratorio aseguran que aún no has
identificado la especie animal que pudo
ser responsable de transferir el virus a
los seres humanos
hoy 9 de febrero inicia el proceso para
el segundo juicio político contra tonal
trump el ahora ex presidente de eeuu
está acusado de incitar a la
insurrección hasta toma el capitolio del
6 de enero se espera que este martes se
debata y se vote sobre la
constitucionalidad de este proceso
aumenta la atención en mi amar tras las
protestas sociales en rechazo al golpe
de estado del primero de febrero la
policía lanzó chorros de agua balas de
goma y gases lacrimógenos contra
manifestantes en ay pido la capital del
país y en mandalay la segunda ciudad más
grande en un intento para dispersar las
movilizaciones luego de que el
movimiento del nuevo gobierno militar
limitara las reuniones de más de cinco
personas
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos la misión de
expertos independientes de la
organización mundial de la salud culminó
su investigación afirmando que no hay
pruebas de la presencia del cob y 19 en
la ciudad china de wuhan antes de
diciembre del año 2019 en una rueda de
prensa aseguraron que el coi 19 podría
haber estado circulando en otras
regiones antes de que fue identificado
en wuhan a finales de 2019 que el animal
que sería la fuente del nuevo
coronavirus aún no ha sido identificado
los expertos calificaron además de
extremadamente improbable la hipótesis
según la cual el virus pudo haberse
filtrado de un laboratorio todo apunta a
que el shark cause 2 procede de
murciélagos y lo más probable es que un
contagio humano a través de una especie
intermediaria
es pinta todo el trabajo que ha sido
hecho sobre este virus tratando de
identificar su origen continúa apuntando
a un reservorio natural de este y otros
virus similares en murciélagos sin
embargo los hallazgos sugieren que la
hipótesis de un incidente de laboratorio
es extremadamente improbable para
explicar la introducción del virus a la
población humana y por ende esta no es
una hipótesis que implicaría a sugerir
estudios futuros en nuestro trabajo para
comprender los orígenes del virus antes
tenía usted origina te faros y cambiamos
de información porque en eeuu se inicia
hoy el proceso para un segundo juicio
político contra el ex presidente de
donald trump y aunque todavía no está
claro cuánto tiempo podrá tomar
representantes de ambos partidos
acordaron las reglas para el
procedimiento por ello vamos hasta
washington dc con nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal muy buen día
hoy empieza entonces este proceso para
el segundo juicio político contra donald
trump en el senado que se debatirá el
día de hoy y cómo será la gente esta
semana
empieza a la una de la tarde hora de
washington n plenaria del senado
jamie rating liderando los demócratas y
los abogados de donald trump en defensa
del ex presidente debatirán si el
segundo caso de impidió ha encontrado a
otro es constitucional tendrán cuatro
horas para hacerlo y entonces sabremos
si el caso sigue adelante a eso de las
cinco de la tarde hora de washington se
espera esta semana que si es aprobado
este caso de impeachment en el senado
entonces los demócratas liderados por
rating presenten sus argumentos
iniciales tendrán 16 horas para hacerlo
y después será la defensa del oro aunque
tenga también 16 horas para hacerlo se
había dicho que la defensa de trump
porque era judía no iba para trabajar el
sábado pero ya pues quitaron esta
solicitud y están dispuestos a trabajar
el sábado si es necesario
ahora cristóbal los demócratas aseguran
tener una evidencia abrumadora sobre la
culpabilidad del ex presidente pero la
defensa de trump
mientras tanto denuncia un proceso
inconstitucional que podemos esperar de
los argumentos de ambas partes
claro los demócratas en un documento de
80 páginas dicen que el único
responsable de lo que pasó en el
capitolio de la toma el 6 de enero fue
donald trump incitando con sus palabras
no solamente en redes sociales sino esa
misma mañana en la casa blanca cuando
invitó a sus simpatizantes a ir al
capitolio y a pues negar los resultados
de la votación electoral en la
presidencia y los republicanos pues en
un documento un poco más corto de 14
páginas se defienden diciendo que pues
ya no hay caso porque el presidente ya
no está en la casa blanca de 18 ya salió
de la casa blanca y además dicen que
pues don otro que tiene todo el derecho
de defenderse y todo el derecho de
expresar lo que él cree eso sobre sobre
todo sobre las elecciones cuando dice
que fue un fraude electoral así que
dicen los abogados de donald trump que
no hay que vincular la violencia de sus
simpatizantes con las creencias que él
expresó ese día antes de la toma del
capitolio que estabas gracias por
información feliz día el gobierno de
colombia anunció la creación de una de
un estatuto de protección temporal para
migrantes venezolanos en el país que
supondrá la regularización de más de 950
mil personas
una decisión histórica en materia de
emigración colombia regularizará
temporalmente a los migrantes
venezolanos nosotros hacemos pública la
decisión de nuestro país
de crear un estatuto de protección
temporal en colombia
que nos permita hacer un proceso de
regularización de esos migrantes que
están en nuestro país la medida acoge a
quienes ya se encuentran en el país de
manera irregular que actualmente son más
de 960.000 los que ya están
regularizados no tendrán que acudir a
estar haciendo actualizaciones
constantes de sus permisos sino que
tendrán un proceso de mayor estabilidad
y a quienes están en nuestro país en
condición de irregulares tendrán una
hoja de ruta a esa regularización pero
con el fin de desincentivar la migración
ilegal quienes entren al país durante
los próximos dos años podrán acogerse a
la vigencia de este estatuto será de
hasta diez años y transcurrido este
tiempo los interesados en seguir en
colombia podrán optar a ser residentes
cifras de acnur señalan que en la
actualidad 5,4 millones de venezolanos
viven fuera de su país de esa cantidad
más de 1,7 millones viven en colombia
muchos de ellos bajo unas difíciles
condiciones humanitarias que el anuncio
de colombia de otorgar protección
temporal a los venezolanos que se
encuentran en su territorio por un
periodo de 10 años es un gesto
humanitario emblemático para la región
con usted existe inclusive para el mundo
interno según migración colombia a pesar
de la pandemia y el cierre de fronteras
se estima que diariamente más de 300
migrantes intentan ingresar de manera
irregular al país
eeuu asegura que el presidente hondureño
juan orlando hernández fue investigado
un documento judicial presentado en una
corte en nueva york con relación a un
caso contra el supuesto narcotraficante
giovanni fuentes ramírez se afirma que
hernandes protegió a traficantes como
parte de un plan para hacerse con el
poder y el control de honduras el
presidente ha negado toda relación con
actividades ligadas al narcotráfico
la oposición haitiana al desafío la
autoridad y legitimidad del presidente
yo en el mois al declarar el fin de su
mandato y nombrar a un presidente
interino un día después de que el
gobierno denunciara un complot para dar
un golpe de estado
el nuevo presidente reconocido
únicamente por la oposición es el
magistrado joseph msn jean-louis decano
de la corte de casación máxima instancia
judicial del país horas después moix
ordenó la jubilación de jean louis y
otros dos jueces opositores por medio de
un decreto presidencial vamos ahora el
informe de álvaro cordero
la fractura política en haití parece
profundizarse día a día la oposición
acusa al presidente joven el mois de
perpetuarse en el poder
al no haber dejado su cargo este 7 de
febrero pero él rechaza esto y alega que
su mandato termina en un año
no soy un dictador sé que mi mandato
termine el 7 de febrero de 2032 mandan
de humala
los dictadores son personas que toman el
poder y no saben cuándo se van
moix defiende que su periodo de
gobernanza es por cinco años mientras
que los opositores aseguran que la
constitución limita los mandatos a
cuatro años la tensión en el país
solamente ha ido en aumento y este
domingo el presidente denunció un
intento de golpe de estado en el que se
detuvo a 23 personas el juez y vi que el
decil ha hecho un complot para dar un
golpe de estado para desestabilizar al
país el poder judicial es uno de los
mayores enemigos de moix a ellos se
suman la iglesia católica y el colegio
de abogados pero el ejército se ha
mantenido leal al mandatario algo que no
ha impedido que este lunes la oposición
nombrará a un presidente interino
estas se han replicado y hubo heridos
por bala
declaro que aceptó la elección de la
oposición y la sociedad civil de servir
a mi país como presidente interino de la
transición
[Música]
haití es el país más pobre de américa la
crisis que sufre se prolonga desde hace
décadas y sobrepasa el plano político
cuarta jornada de protestas masivas
contra el golpe de estado en mianmar en
varias ciudades del país la policía
disparó balas de goma y cañones de agua
contra los manifestantes que desafiaron
la prohibición de reuniones impuestas
por los militares la detención de la
respuesta lideran sanssouci el primero
de febrero ha desatado el mayor
movimiento de protestas en más de una
década en ese país
a pesar de los cañones de agua estos
manifestantes en naypyidaw continúan
levantando tres dedos un símbolo de
desafío frente al golpe de estado de
hace una semana y la oleada de nuevas
leyes que ilegalizan las protestas el
ejército ha prohibido cualquier reunión
de más de cinco personas pero grandes
multitudes siguen saliendo a la calle
para pedir la liberación de aung san suu
kyi y el regreso de su gobierno en la
capital económica del país manifestantes
se han reunido en la sede del partido de
la líder de puesta
[Aplausos]
aunque el gobierno militar y sus
anuncios no los aceptamos no lo
reconocemos como nuestro gobierno
oficial ya que solo reconocemos a
nuestro presidente como jefe del
gobierno oficial
resistiremos las leyes del gobierno
militar de alguna forma u otra
el lunes el jefe de la junta militar dio
su primer discurso televisado desde el
golpe de estado prometió unas elecciones
justas en un año aunque sin fijar una
fecha para llegar allí cuando
completemos un año de ley marcial
tendremos elecciones multipartidistas
y le daremos el poder al ganador según
las leyes de la democracia que mujeres y
senés anuncian allí
la ola de la desobediencia civil crece
ya ha llegado a escuelas hospitales y
oficinas del gobierno
mientras se mantienen las protestas más
grandes de los últimos diez años el
ejército ya ha arrestado a docenas de
personas y la gente se pregunta hasta
dónde están dispuestos a llegar para
mantenerse en el poder
[Música]
en india los equipos de rescate
continúan trabajando luego del desastre
provocado por el colapso de un glaciar
ubicado en la cordillera del himalaya
hasta el momento se registran por lo
menos 26 muertes y casi 200 personas
desaparecidas el informe de matías a
rayas
en la región de uttar acan en india
desde el domingo los equipos de rescate
no dejaron de trabajar buscando en los
escombros excavando todos los métodos
son buenos para salvar una vida tras la
catástrofe hasta ahora hemos avanzado un
poco y el túnel no se ha abierto todavía
se han recuperado 26 cuerpos y las
operaciones de rescate están en marcha
señor cuál es el plan para hoy hoy
esperamos poder abrir el túnel por la
tarde
alrededor de 200 personas siguen
desaparecidas después de que parte de un
remoto glaciar del himalaya se
desprendiera el domingo destruyendo
puentes rompiendo presas y enviando un
torrente de agua rocas y escombros por
un valle unas imágenes difundidas por la
televisión local mostraban a un hombre
que salía de un túnel del proyecto
hidroeléctrico en construcción las
brigadas de rescate se han centrado en
perforar el túnel de 25 kilómetros de
longitud para alcanzar los posibles
sobrevivientes aquí tenemos una
estrategia en la que podemos trabajar
con dos máquinas allí se está trabajando
en ello para que puedan ser rescatadas
pronto estamos tratando de llegar a las
30 a 35 personas que sospechamos están
atrapadas en el túnel habitan
los expertos creen que las fuertes
nevadas seguidas por jornadas soleadas
provocaron un derretimiento que dio
origen a la avalancha grupos
ambientalistas señalan la construcción
de hidroeléctricas en esta zona
montañosa como la responsable por el
desastre ahora también está en tela de
juicio la solidez de las presas que en
teoría deberían poder soportar torrentes
de esta magnitud
en la sonda home de los emiratos árabes
unidos entrará en la órbita de marte en
la primera misión del país al planeta
rojo
la sonda orbitar a el planeta y
proporcionará una imagen completa de la
atmósfera marciana estudiando los
cambios diarios y también estacionales
esta misión costó unos 200 millones de
dólares aproximadamente
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continue con nosotros buen
día
[Música]
france24 en español sigue